hi Matt Welch here with nick gillespie
it's asked a libertarian day going into
its semi final stretch we're here to
answer your questions and talk a bit
about the themes in the Declaration of
Independence which is newly out in
paperback the next question comes in via
facebook joshua walker asks what is the
libertarian plan for fixing the debt and
deficit problem not generalities but
specific points Nick you know I think
was the last year at some point myself
and frequent collaborator a reason
economics columnist Veronique to Russia
wrote a story called the nineteen
percent solution where we showed how you
could balance the budget over ten years
without raising taxes simply by
maintaining basically current levels of
spending keeping them in the historic
range of revenue of nineteen percent of
GDP that would be a great first start
and over time you basically keep federal
spending constant and start working down
get rid of entitlements that entitlement
spending that is run out of control
provide a safety net for people which
this is a subject of a forthcoming cover
story and reason and that's the basic
way to get get things going we have a
spending problem in the United States we
do not particularly have a revenue
problem because we have shown time and
time again that we're willing to spend
you two forty percent more than we're
willing to take it in revenue the real
problem is bringing spending down not
necessarily raising revenues the federal
budget in 2001 of Bill Clinton's last
was 1.8 trillion dollars and Barack
Obama's first it was 3.6 trillion
dollars that's I think that's double
there's some you know time off for
inflation and population growth which is
around ten percent during that time but
it really shows that we goose the hell
out of government by we I do mean george
w bush and the Republican majority did a
lot of that and those who believe that
government spending is the great engine
of job creation I think have a difficult
time answering well where'd all them
jobs go or
certainly have a lot higher unemployment
now than we did then we have another
issue that I recommend people look up
called how to slash spending it was a 3d
issue with a terrible knife coming
through the cover with really concrete
proposals for how do you do things like
unwind fannie and freddie which is just
a nightmare not and how do you close and
what are some test cases in the past in
canada in new zealand and in the united
states after world war two where people
cut federal budgets pretty significantly
and saw surprise surprise economic
growth as a direct result so we have
pragmatic solutions all up and down the
street on that please refer to them at
reason.com on our cover gallery ask a
libertarian 2012 we'll be right back
you